- Selamat datang kembali ke Memahami Maklumat
dan Pengiraan Kuantum.
Nama saya John Watrous, dan saya adalah pengarah teknikal
Pendidikan di IBM Quantum.
Ini adalah pelajaran kedua dalam siri ini. Kalau korang belum
tengok pelajaran pertama lagi, pastikan check dulu.
Kita akan bina terus dari apa yang kita bincangkan
dalam pelajaran pertama, jadi penting untuk faham
bahan tu sebelum masuk pelajaran ni.
Selain tu, tahu je la bahawa siri ni
ada kandungan buku teks selain video, dan korang boleh jumpa pautan
ke kandungan buku teks tu
dalam penerangan video. Ini adalah pelajaran dua dari
unit satu dalam siri ni.
Unit satu meliputi asas-asas
maklumat kuantum.
Dalam pelajaran sebelumnya, kita bincangkan maklumat kuantum dalam konteks sistem tunggal, maksudnya kita ada satu
sistem yang menyimpan maklumat
dan kita huraikan macam mana
ia berfungsi secara berasingan.
Kita habiskan masa yang agak banyak untuk
maklumat klasikal, terutamanya untuk wujudkan titik rujukan dan nak tonjolkan persamaan
matematik
antara maklumat kuantum dan klasikal.
Kita juga nampak macam mana keadaan kuantum boleh diwakili oleh vektor, khususnya vektor yang mempunyai
entri nombor kompleks dan norma Euclidean sama dengan satu,
dan kita bincangkan pengukuran
asas standard dan operasi unitari.
Dalam pelajaran ni, kita nak perluaskan
pandangan kita ke berbilang sistem, di mana setiap satunya mampu
menyimpan maklumat kuantum.
Ini bukan sekadar cakap bahawa setiap sistem individu
berfungsi macam yang kita bincang kali lepas, ada maksudnya di mana keseluruhannya
lebih besar dari jumlah bahagiannya, dan tu pun betul untuk
maklumat klasikal bila kebarangkalian terlibat.
Berbilang sistem boleh
berinteraksi antara satu sama lain dan ia boleh berkorelasi
antara satu sama lain contohnya, dan dalam konteks kuantum, ini termasuk kemungkinan
bahawa sistem-sistem tu berentangle, iaitu istilah yang mungkin
pernah korang dengar sebelum ni.
Entanglement adalah fenomena yang sangat
penting dalam maklumat kuantum dan kita akan ada banyak lagi perkara nak cakap tentangnya bila siri ni terus.
Tapi ada prinsip mudah yang memberi kita banyak landasan untuk berfikir dan
memahami maklumat kuantum untuk berbilang sistem,
iaitu kita sentiasa boleh
ambil dua atau lebih sistem dan gabungkan atau sekadar secara konseptual
fikirkan ia bersama-sama
dan tengok ia macam ia membentuk
satu sistem kompaun tunggal.
Dan bila kita fikirkan tentang
sistem kompaun macam ni, seolah-olah ia satu sistem, kita sedar ia mesti dihuraikan dengan cara yang konsisten
dengan semua yang kita pelajari
dalam pelajaran sebelumnya tentang sistem tunggal.
Kita akan tengok macam mana ini berfungsi
dan macam mana huraian maklumat kuantum
untuk berbilang sistem muncul dengan agak semula jadi dari macam mana ia berfungsi untuk sistem tunggal
berdasarkan prinsip satu ni. Ni gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran dan kebetulan ia sama dengan gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran sebelumnya,
tapi kali ni fokus kita
akan pada berbilang sistem bukan sistem tunggal.
Macam yang kita buat dalam pelajaran sebelumnya dan untuk sebab yang sama, kita akan mulakan dengan
maklumat klasikal.
Sekali lagi, kita akan nampak
persamaan yang sangat rapat antara cara maklumat kuantum
dan klasikal berfungsi di peringkat matematik.
Kita biasanya tak fokus sangat
pada maklumat klasikal atau mulakan setiap pelajaran dalam siri ni dengan maklumat klasikal macam ni.
Pelajaran-pelajaran seterusnya cenderung untuk lebih fokus secara eksklusif pada maklumat dan pengiraan kuantum.
Tapi kat permulaan ni
ini adalah pendekatan yang masuk akal dan ia kembali kepada idea bahawa berfikir tentang maklumat klasikal
boleh jadi sumber panduan yang berharga untuk memahami maklumat kuantum.
Kita juga akan bincangkan
konsep penting tensor product dalam
bahagian pelajaran ni.
Tensor product adalah sangat penting dalam maklumat kuantum, tapi ia juga timbul dalam
konteks klasikal.
Kemudian kita akan beralih ke maklumat kuantum dan lebih kurang macam dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita akan bincangkan keadaan kuantum,
pengukuran asas standard,
dan operasi unitari kali ni
untuk berbilang sistem.
Kita akan mulakan dengan bercakap
tentang keadaan klasikal berbilang sistem.
Ingat dari pelajaran sebelumnya
bahawa keadaan klasikal sesebuah sistem ialah
konfigurasi sistem tu yang boleh dikenali dan
dihuraikan tanpa kesamaran
tanpa sebarang ketidakpastian atau kesilapan. Dan dalam istilah matematik, bila kita merujuk kepada set keadaan klasikal,
kita hanya maksudkan set yang terhingga dan tidak kosong.
Kita akan mulakan perbincangan kita
tentang berbilang sistem dengan mengandaikan bahawa kita ada
hanya dua sistem X dan Y.
X ada satu set keadaan klasikal yang kita akan panggil sigma macam
dalam pelajaran sebelumnya, dan Y ada set keadaan klasikal
yang kita panggil gamma. Set sigma dan gamma
boleh jadi set yang sama atau berbeza,
tapi kita bagi nama yang berbeza, bukan sahaja sebab ia
boleh jadi set yang berbeza, tapi juga sebab ia akan
membantu kita kekalkan kejelasan kalau kita bagi nama yang berbeza.
Kita akan dapati bahawa adalah
agak mudah untuk generalisasikan keseluruhan perbincangan ni dari dua sistem ke mana-mana bilangan sistem, tapi
dengan bermula dari dua sistem,
kita boleh fokus pada idea-idea asas tanpa terjebak dalam butiran.
WEBVTT
Sekarang, bayangkan kita
letak X dan Y bersebelahan dengan X di kiri dan Y di kanan, dan kita tengok dua sistem ni bersama-sama
seolah-olah ia membentuk satu sistem kompaun tunggal.
Untuk bagi nama kepada sistem baru ni, kita boleh tuliskan ia sebagai
pasangan tertib macam ni, atau kita boleh hanya tulis sebelah
kedua-dua huruf macam ni.
Kedua-duanya biasa dan kita
boleh pilih mana-mana yang kita nak atau mana-mana yang lebih mudah.
Mana-mana cara pun, kita akan baca ia sebagai XY.
Soalan yang sangat semula jadi
untuk ditanya pada ketika ni ialah apakah keadaan klasikal sistem kompaun baru XY ni?
Dan jawapan kepada soalan tu ialah set keadaan klasikal XY adalah hasil darab Cartesian
kedua-dua set keadaan klasikal,
sigma dan gamma, yang boleh korang
lihat ditakrifkan kat sini.
Pada sesuatu masa, X ada keadaan klasikal
yang merupakan elemen sigma, dan Y ada keadaan klasikal
yang merupakan elemen gamma,
dan kita hanya fikirkan
tentang dua keadaan ni bersama-sama seolah-olah ia membentuk satu keadaan, dan itulah tepat konsep yang
hasil darab Cartesian tangkap. Kita ada dua elemen,
satu dari setiap set kita, dan kita nak fikirkan
tentang dua elemen ni bersama-sama
seolah-olah ia membentuk satu
elemen dari satu set tunggal.
Untuk jelaskan, ada andaian kat sini iaitu kita tahu
yang mana satu sistem kita adalah X dan yang mana satu adalah Y,
dan tak ada kekeliruan antara keduanya. Tak penting bahawa X berada di sebelah kiri secara fizikal
dan Y di sebelah kanan,
sebaliknya yang penting ialah kedua-dua
sistem boleh dibezakan dan kita dah putuskan
untuk menyusunnya cara ni supaya kita boleh kekalkan
mana satu yang mana.
Ni contoh sangat mudah di mana sigma adalah abjad binari dan gamma adalah set
yang mengandungi empat suit kad.
Kalau X menyimpan nilai binari dan Y menyimpan satu dari empat suit kad, maka ada lapan
keadaan klasikal yang mungkin
bagi pasangan XY, yang boleh korang
lihat disenaraikan kat sini.
Untuk lebih dari dua sistem, ini tergeneral dengan cara yang mudah.
Khususnya kalau X1 hingga Xn adalah sistem yang mempunyai
set keadaan klasikal sigma satu hingga sigma n masing-masing.
Maka kalau kita bayangkan mengelompokkan
n sistem tu bersama-sama dan melihatnya sebagai satu sistem, set keadaan klasikal diberikan oleh hasil darab Cartesian
bagi n set keadaan klasikal
sigma satu hingga sigma n.
Seperti yang boleh korang lihat kat sini pada skrin. Hasil darab Cartesian
boleh ditakrifkan macam ni untuk sebarang bilangan set.
Contohnya, kalau kita ada tiga sistem dan semuanya berkongsi abjad binari sebagai set keadaan klasikal mereka, jadi dengan kata lain kita ada tiga bit,
maka ada lapan
keadaan klasikal yang mungkin bagi tiga bit yang dilihat
bersama-sama sebagai satu sistem dan korang boleh lihat ia disenaraikan kat sini.
Setiap sistem secara individu boleh
berada dalam keadaan sifar atau satu, dan kita susun semua
kombinasi yang mungkin.
Satu n-tupel keadaan klasikal boleh ditulis secara alternatif sebagai rentetan di mana kita buang
kurungan dan koma macam yang korang nampak kat sini.
Dan ini adalah sangat masuk akal bila kita fikirkan tentang
keadaan klasikal sebagai simbol macam dalam contoh yang sangat biasa
abjad binari
yang kita terus kembali ke situ. Kadang-kadang sangat mudah untuk buat ni dan ia cenderung membuat
ungkapan kita lebih mudah
dan kurang bersepah. Konsep rentetan sebenarnya dirumuskan
dalam istilah matematik melalui hasil darab Carte,
jadi ini sebenarnya hanya
notasi alternatif dan bukan sesuatu yang berbeza secara konseptual.
Sebagai contoh, katakan kita ada
10 bit X1 hingga X10.
Itu bermaksud set keadaan klasikal bagi 10 bit bersama-sama,
yang mungkin secara semula jadi korang fikirkan sebagai daftar 10 bit
dalam komputer contohnya,
adalah hasil darab Cartesian sepuluh kali
bagi abjad binari dengan dirinya sendiri.
Dan kalau kita tuliskan keadaan tu macam rentetan, ia kelihatan macam yang korang tengok kat
sini, ada 1,024 daripada ia,
jadi tentulah ia tak semua disenaraikan kat sini. Tiga titik ni kat sini
sepatutnya menunjukkan ada corak yang boleh korang dedukkan
dan harap korang faham ideanya. Sekarang ada konvensyen
yang kita akan ikut untuk menyusun elemen
set hasil darab Cartesian,
dan adalah penting untuk
menjelaskan ni demi mewakili kedua-dua keadaan kebarangkalian dan keadaan kuantum sebagai vektor.
Konvensyennya ialah kita menyusun elemen
set hasil darab Cartesian secara leksikografi, yang pada asasnya hanya
bermaksud susunan kamus.
Lebih spesifik, kita mulakan dengan andaian bahawa setiap set individu yang kita ambil hasil darab Cartesiannya dah ada susunannya sendiri
dan kita fikirkan tentang
n-tupel tertentu atau rentetan seolah-olah ia satu perkataan dan kita susunnya mengikut abjad.
Cara lain untuk cakap ni ialah kedudukan dalam
n-tupel atau rentetan menurun kepentingannya
dari kiri ke kanan,
macam bila kita tulis nombor menggunakan digit sifar hingga sembilan.
Ni contoh yang
bertujuan untuk menjelaskan perkara ni.
Kalau kita ambil hasil darab Cartesian antara set yang mengandungi
satu, dua, dan tiga dan abjad binari, kita dapat set yang mengandungi enam elemen
dan kat sini ia disenaraikan dalam
susunan yang sedang dihuraikan.
Semua elemen dengan
satu di kedudukan pertama datang sebelum semua elemen dengan dua di kedudukan pertama dan ia datang sebelum semua elemen
WEBVTT
dengan tiga di kedudukan pertama. Dan bila dua elemen
bersetuju di kedudukan pertama, kita guna balik susunan
di kedudukan kedua.
Jadi itulah susunan yang
kita guna untuk hasil darab Cartesian.
Perasan bahawa bila kita guna konvensyen ni dan kita tulis n-tupel sebagai rentetan, kita perhatikan beberapa corak yang sangat biasa.
Contohnya, hasil darab Cartesian bagi
abjad binari dengan dirinya sendiri disusun macam yang korang nampak kat sini,
dan korang boleh fikirkan tentang rentetan-rentetan ni sebagai disusun secara berangka kalau korang ambil rentetan ni
sebagai pengekodan binari integer bukan negatif dan ini tergeneral
ke sebarang panjang rentetan. Beralih ke keadaan kebarangkalian, kita dah tahu dari pelajaran sebelumnya
bahawa keadaan kebarangkalian mengaitkan kebarangkalian dengan setiap keadaan klasikal
bagi sistem tertentu.
Kalau kita ada sistem kompaun di mana kita dah ambil dua atau lebih sistem dan kita tengok ia secara kolektif seolah-olah ia membentuk satu
sistem macam yang kita baru bincangkan,
maka keadaan kebarangkalian
bagi sistem kompaun ni mesti menetapkan kebarangkalian kepada elemen hasil darab Cartesian
bagi sistem-sistem individu,
set keadaan klasikal. Tu sebabnya itulah
set keadaan klasikal bagi sistem kompaun tu.
Sebagai contoh, andaikan
X dan Y adalah bit, kita ada contoh ni keadaan
kebarangkalian XY.
Kebarangkalian kedua-dua
bit adalah sifar ialah satu perdua dan kebarangkalian kedua-dua
bit adalah satu ialah satu perdua, jadi dua bit tu tak pernah tak sepakat.
Ia adalah keadaan kebarangkalian yang sah bagi XY, dan kita boleh tulis ia secara alternatif
sebagai vektor
macam yang korang nampak kat sini dan kat sini korang boleh nampak bahawa kita
mengikut konvensyen yang saya huraikan tadi untuk menyusun keadaan klasikal ni.
Ini adalah contoh
keadaan kebarangkalian di mana X dan Y berkorelasi, dan inilah maksudnya keseluruhannya
lebih besar dari jumlah bahagiannya. Macam yang saya cadangkan tadi, ia bukan sekadar bahawa kita
ada keadaan kebarangkalian
bagi X dan keadaan kebarangkalian bagi Y dan kita gabungkan ia, sebaliknya kita dahulukan
gabungkan sistem-sistem tu
kemudian kita fikirkan tentang
keadaan kebarangkalian bagi sistem kompaun.
Untuk lebih tepat tentang
korelasi antara sistem. Kita mulakan dengan mentakrifkan
konsep kebebasan, yang pada dasarnya adalah
ketiadaan korelasi.
Di sini, istilah kebebasan merujuk
kepada kebebasan statistik berbeza dari kebebasan linear
vektor contohnya.
Ia adalah konsep asas dalam
kebarangkalian dan statistik.
Kalau kita ada dua sistem X dan Y dan kita ada keadaan kebarangkalian
bagi XY, maka kita cakap X dan Y adalah bebas.
Kalau formula yang korang
lihat kat sini adalah benar untuk setiap pilihan keadaan klasikal
a dan b bagi X dan Y.
Satu cara untuk tafsirkan
syarat kebebasan ni ialah ia cakap bahawa kebarangkalian bagi X berada dalam mana-mana satu keadaan klasikal
dan kebarangkalian bagi Y berada dalam keadaan klasikal lain langsung
tak ada kena mengena antara satu sama lain.
Jadi, mengetahui keadaan mana
satu dari sistem itu tak mempengaruhi
kebarangkalian yang dikaitkan dengan keadaan sistem lain.
Kalau korang bayangkan memilih secara rawak
keadaan klasikal X mengikut prosedur tertentu dan kemudian memilih secara rawak
keadaan klasikal Y
mengikut prosedur lain yang tak dalam apa-apa cara
disambungkan kepada yang untuk X, macam katakan kalau seorang orang balik syiling
dan orang lain di
bilik yang berbeza golek dadu, maka inilah formula
yang korang guna untuk dapatkan kebarangkalian
bagi kombinasi yang berbeza
keadaan untuk muncul. Tujuan takrifan ni ialah kebebasan adalah
bila formulanya sah.
Bila kita fikirkan tentang keadaan kebarangkalian dalam istilah vektor kebarangkalian, ada rumusan mudah
bagi syarat ni
khususnya kalau kita ada
keadaan kebarangkalian XY, yang boleh kita ungkapkan sebagai
vektor dalam notasi ket
macam yang korang nampak kat sini. Maka untuk cakap X dan Y adalah bebas adalah bersamaan dengan kewujudan
dua vektor kebarangkalian,
ket Phi dan ket Psi yang mana kita boleh
baca sahaja sebagai Phi dan Psi demi keringkasan mewakili
keadaan kebarangkalian X dan Y secara berasingan yang memenuhi kesamaan ni
yang korang nampak kat sini.
Untuk semua pilihan a dan b, ia pada dasarnya adalah
pengulangan takrifan dalam istilah vektor.
Contohnya, ni adalah keadaan kebarangkalian
pasangan bit XY di mana X dan Y adalah bebas.
Syarat yang
diperlukan untuk kebebasan adalah benar untuk vektor
yang korang nampak kat sini.
Iaitu kebarangkalian
bagi setiap tetapan yang mungkin untuk dua bit diberikan oleh hasil darab kebarangkalian yang sepadan
bagi bit-bit individu.
Contohnya, kebarangkalian bagi kedua-dua
bit mengambil nilai sifar adalah sama dengan satu perenam, yang sama dengan satu
perempat kali dua pertiga,
dan begitu juga untuk
tiga kemungkinan lain yang boleh disemak satu persatu.
Untuk keadaan kebarangkalian yang kita nampak tadi di satu pihak di mana kita
ada dua bit yang sentiasa bersetuju dan mengambil nilai sifar dan
satu dengan kebarangkalian satu perdua
kita tak ada kebebasan dan itulah sebabnya kita cakap
bit-bit itu berkorelasi.
Korelasi hanya bermaksud
ketiadaan kebebasan.
Cara mudah untuk berhujah bahawa
dua bit tu tak bebas ialah dengan mengandaikan ia bebas dan mendapat percanggahan
khususnya kalau dua
bit tu adalah bebas, mesti ada
nombor q0, q1, r0 dan r1
WEBVTT
yang mewakili kebarangkalian
bagi dua bit individu supaya persamaan-persamaan
ni kat sini dipenuhi.
Ni adalah kebarangkalian
yang datang dari vektor kita dan ni adalah
persamaan-persamaan yang mesti benar mengikut syarat kebebasan,
tapi kalau kita tengok kesamaan
kedua kat sini, kita nampak ia menuntut bahawa
q0 kali r1 sama dengan sifar,
tapi satu-satunya cara hasil darab dua nombor nyata boleh
menjadi sama dengan sifar ialah kalau sekurang-kurangnya satu dari
nombor tu sendiri sama dengan sifar.
Ini kadang-kadang dipanggil
sifat hasil darab sifar nombor nyata.
Cara lain untuk cakap ia ialah hasil darab dua nombor nyata bukan sifar
sentiasa bukan sifar.
Jadi kesamaan kat sini
membayangkan sama ada q0 sama dengan sifar atau r1 sama dengan sifar,
tapi dari kesamaan pertama dan terakhir kita nampak bahawa mana-mana
dua alternatif tu tak mungkin benar.
Kalau q0 sama dengan sifar, maka hasil darab ni mesti sama dengan sifar, tapi ia tak sama dengan sifar
dan kalau r1 sama dengan sifar,
maka hasil darab ni mesti sama dengan sifar, tapi tu pun tak benar.
Jadi kita ada percanggahan
dan kita simpulkan bahawa X dan Y tak bebas jadi ia berkorelasi.
Konsep kebebasan
yang kita baru bincangkan dan khususnya rumusannya dalam istilah vektor kebarangkalian sangat berkait rapat
dengan operasi yang boleh
dilakukan ke atas vektor yang dikenali sebagai tensor product.
Tensor product boleh
ditakrifkan bukan sahaja untuk vektor tetapi juga untuk matriks
dan sebenarnya konsep tensor product boleh ditakrifkan
untuk banyak jenis objek
matematik yang lain juga.
Ia boleh dihuraikan
dengan cara yang agak abstrak yang penting dan
berguna dalam matematik tulen, tapi kita juga boleh takrifkan
tensor product untuk vektor
dengan cara yang sangat mudah dan konkrit, dan itulah laluan yang
kita akan ambil dalam pelajaran ni.
Kalau kita ada dua vektor lajur Phi dan Psi yang ditulis dalam bentuk yang korang nampak kat sini di mana sigma dan gamma adalah mana-mana
pilihan set keadaan klasikal
yang kita suka atau indeks kalau korang prefer, maka tensor product vektor-vektor ni adalah vektor yang korang nampak kat sini.
Kita susun semua elemen
hasil darab Cartesian dua set, sigma dan gamma, dan entri vektor yang bersesuaian
dengan setiap pasangan ab, yang
ditulis sebagai rentetan kat sini, adalah sama dengan hasil darab entri
yang bersesuaian
bagi dua vektor ni. Dengan kata lain, entri ab bagi Phi tensor Psi adalah hasil darab entri a
bagi Phi dan entri b bagi Psi,
dan itulah maksud apa
yang ditulis kat sini.
Pada dasarnya, ini adalah operasi yang sama yang kita baru nampak beberapa saat tadi bila kita bincangkan kebebasan
dan sekarang kita hanya bagi nama kepadanya.
Ni adalah tepat contoh yang sama
yang kita nampak tadi ditulis dengan lebih eksplisit dalam
istilah tensor product.
Sekali lagi, kita ada satu perenam sama dengan satu perempat kali satu pertiga, satu per dua belas sama dengan satu perempat
kali satu pertiga dan seterusnya.
Di sini, ngomong-ngomong ada
beberapa cara alternatif untuk menulis tensor
product dua vektor.
Bila kita guna notasi ket dan kita tulis dua ket bersebelahan
macam ni, ia bermaksud tensor product.
Jadi korang boleh fikirkan tentang tensor product sebagai cara lalai untuk darabkan dua vektor lajur bersama-sama.
Tak masuk akal
untuk fikirkan tentang hasil darab vektor lajur macam ni dalam istilah pendaraban matriks sebab dimensinya tak betul,
jadi memang tak ada sebab
nak risau tentang kesamaran kat sini.
Kita juga boleh tulis
tensor product macam ni di dalam ket dan ia bermaksud
tepat perkara yang sama.
Ia adalah tensor product
bagi dua vektor.
Yang pertama sangat biasa dan sebenarnya mungkin lebih biasa untuk tulis tensor product macam ni tanpa simbol tensor product
berbanding dengan menyertakan simbol tu. Yang kedua
memang kurang biasa, tapi ia kadang-kadang sangat berguna terutamanya
sebagai cara untuk menghapuskan keperluan
untuk kurungan tambahan dalam situasi tertentu.
Kita juga boleh ungkapkan
tensor product secara eksplisit dalam istilah lajur nombor sebenar macam yang korang nampak kat sini,
kalau kita ambil tensor product dua vektor lajur ni kat sini, maka ni adalah vektor yang kita dapat
dan korang boleh nampak bahawa entri kat sini adalah hasil darab entri
yang datang dari dua vektor ni.
Susunan entri
tensor product adalah konsisten dengan
takrifan dari tadi dengan syarat kita ikut konvensyen
yang saya huraikan tadi untuk menyusun elemen
set hasil darab Cartesian.
Mengikut konvensyen tu bersamaan dengan berfikir
tentang indeks vektor pertama sebagai
mempunyai kepentingan lebih tinggi berbanding indeks vektor kedua,
jadi korang boleh nampak bahawa
bila kita melalui entri tensor product, kita ada semua hasil darab yang melibatkan entri pertama
vektor di sebelah kiri,
iaitu alpha satu. Kemudian semua hasil darab
yang melibatkan entri kedua vektor di sebelah kiri,
iaitu alpha dua dan seterusnya.
Ni adalah contoh di mana
vektor di sebelah kiri ada tiga entri dan vektor di
sebelah kanan ada empat entri jadi kita boleh nampak lebih
jelas apa yang berlaku.
WEBVTT
Kita ada tiga entri dalam vektor pertama, jadi kita mulakan dengan menulis tiga salinan vektor kedua kemudian kita darabkan setiap satu dari salinan tu
dengan entri yang bersesuaian
dalam vektor pertama macam ni.
Kita bawa alpha masuk ke dalam macam ni, dan kat sini kita hanya
mendarabkan vektor dengan skalar
dan akhirnya kita buang
kurungan dari salinan-salinan dan kita bentukkan satu vektor lajur
tunggal macam yang korang nampak kat sini.
Sebagai hal penting yang perlu diberi perhatian, nampak bahawa kita ada formula-formula berikut untuk tensor product
vektor asas standard.
Kalau kita ambil tensor
product bagi ket a dan ket b, yang boleh kita tulis dengan
simbol tensor product atau tanpa, macam yang korang nampak kat sini,
maka hasilnya adalah hanya ket ab.
Kalau kita nak tulis ab sebagai pasangan tertib berbanding rentetan, kita boleh buat tu dan kita dapat
ungkapan ni kat sini,
tapi jauh lebih biasa
untuk tulis ni kat sini di mana kita buang kurungan
tapi kita tinggalkan koma.
Ada makna di mana
yang dengan kurungan ni mungkin lebih betul, tapi ia adalah konvensyen standard yang cukup dalam matematik
bahawa kurungan dibuang bila ia tak diperlukan atau berguna.
Korang boleh fikirkan ia sebagai tersirat dalam yang ni kat sini dan ia hanya kurang bersepah
dan lebih senang dipandang.
Tensor product ada
sifat penting iaitu ia bilinear dan maksudnya ia adalah linear
dalam setiap dua argumen dengan syarat yang satu lagi ditetapkan.
Dengan lebih terperinci ia
adalah linear dalam argumen pertama yang dinyatakan oleh dua persamaan yang korang nampak kat sini,
yang pertama cakap bahawa
kalau kita tambahkan dua vektor, Phi1 dan Phi2 dan kemudian ambil
tensor product dengan Psi, kita dapat hasil yang sama kalau
kita ambil tensor product
dengan Psi dahulu kemudian kita tambahkan.
Yang kedua cakap bahawa kalau
kita darabkan vektor Phi dengan skalar alpha dan kemudian kita ambil
tensor product dengan Psi,
hasilnya adalah sama macam kalau kita dahulukan ambil tensor product Phi dan Psi kemudian kita darabkan hasilnya dengan alpha.
Dan kita juga ada lineariti
dalam argumen kedua yang sama kecuali peranan dua argumen ditukar.
Sifat bilinear ni
agak mudah untuk disahkan dari takrifan, tapi baik untuk tuliskannya macam ni sebab kita kerap akan
guna formula-formula ni.
Perasan ngomong-ngomong bahawa skalar bergerak bebas melalui tensor product dalam erti kata yang dinyatakan oleh
kesamaan-kesamaan yang korang nampak kat sini.
Iaitu tak ada perbezaan
antara mendarabkan argumen pertama dengan
skalar alpha dalam kes ni mendarabkan argumen kedua
dengan skalar tu
atau mendarabkan keseluruhan
perkara dengan skalar tu.
Kesamaan-kesamaan ni ikut dari
dua persamaan kat sini dan sebab tak ada
perbezaan antara vektor-vektor ni, kita boleh tulis
ungkapan macam yang korang nampak kat sini
tanpa kurungan sebab
tak perlu pun.
Ia tak menambah kejelasan
atau menghilangkan kesamaran, jadi kita hanya buangnya dan
kita dapat ungkapan yang lebih bersih.
Semua ni tergeneral
ke tiga atau lebih sistem.
Kita boleh takrifkan tensor product
bagi tiga atau lebih vektor dengan menggeneralisasikan formula
untuk tensor product dua vektor dengan cara yang semula jadi,
yang boleh korang nampak dinyatakan kat sini. Setiap entri tensor product diberikan oleh hasil darab
entri yang bersesuaian
bagi vektor-vektor yang kita
ambil tensor productnya.
Cara bersamaan untuk
mentakrifkan tensor product tiga atau lebih vektor
ialah dengan melakukannya secara rekursif akhirnya kembali kepada takrifan
tensor product antara dua vektor. Jadi kalau n sekurang-kurangnya tiga, kita boleh fikirkan tentang
tensor product n vektor
Phi1 hingga Phi n sebagai tensor product antara vektor apa pun yang kita dapat dengan
mengambil tensor product n tolak satu yang pertama
daripadanya dengan vektor terakhir,
dan kalau korang nak tahu
apa tensor product bagi n tolak satu vektor yang pertama, korang sama ada guna formula
sekali lagi dalam kes n tolak satu
sekurang-kurangnya tiga atau guna takrifan
dari sebelumnya kalau n tolak satu sama dengan dua.
Dua cara untuk berfikir
tentang tensor product tiga atau lebih vektor adalah bersamaan.
Kali ni bila kita ada
tiga atau lebih vektor yang kita ambil tensor productnya, kita tak guna istilah bilinear,
kita guna istilah multilinear,
tapi ideanya adalah sama.
Tensor product adalah linear
dalam setiap kedudukan dengan syarat vektor-vektor di
semua kedudukan lain
ditetapkan. Beralih ke pengukuran
berbilang sistem dalam keadaan kebarangkalian,
kita segera dapat spesifikasi untuk macam mana pengukuran
berfungsi untuk berbilang sistem dengan sekadar berfikir tentangnya
secara kolektif sebagai sistem tunggal
dengan syarat semua
sistem diukur.
Sebagai contoh mudah, katakan kita ada dua
bit X dan Y dan secara kolektif ia berada dalam keadaan kebarangkalian
ni kat sini,
yang kita nampak sebelum ni. Secara semula jadi, kalau kita ukur
kedua-dua bit ni, kita akan dapat hasil 00
maksudnya sifar untuk pengukuran pertama dan sifar untuk pengukuran kedua dengan kebarangkalian satu perdua dan kita akan dapat hasil 1,1
WEBVTT
dengan kebarangkalian satu perdua juga. Tu memang sangat mudah.
Pada dasarnya, mengukur semua sistem adalah bersamaan dengan mengukur
keseluruhan sistem kompaun.
Kalau kita tak ukur semua
sistem walau bagaimanapun, sebaliknya kita hanya ukur
sebahagian daripada sistem, maka situasinya tak
begitu jelas dengan serta-merta
dengan mengehadkan perhatian kita sekali lagi kepada kes hanya dua
sistem untuk nampak intipati apa yang berlaku dalam
persekitaran semudah yang mungkin.
Kita boleh tanya soalan berikut, katakan kita ada dua sistem, X dan Y yang bersama-sama sebagai pasangan
dalam keadaan kebarangkalian tertentu.
Apa yang berlaku kalau kita ukur
hanya X dan kita tak buat apa-apa kepada Y?
Kita boleh jawab soalan ni menggunakan beberapa teori kebarangkalian asas.
Pertama, kita tahu bahawa kebarangkalian pengukuran
memberikan hasil tertentu mesti diberikan oleh formula
yang korang nampak kat sini.
Kita boleh fikirkan tentang kebarangkalian bagi setiap
keadaan klasikal pasangan XY seolah-olah kita ukur kedua-duanya dan kita jumlahkan semua kebarangkalian
yang konsisten dengan X berada dalam mana-mana keadaan klasikal
a yang kita minati.
Jadi itulah sebabnya hasil tambah kat sini hanya merangkumi keadaan klasikal b bagi Y.
Satu cara untuk fikirkan tentang
formula ni ialah kebarangkalian melihat keadaan klasikal tertentu X kalau kita ukurnya
mesti konsisten dengan kebarangkalian melihat keadaan tu kalau
kita juga ukur Y, walaupun kita tak ukur pun,
tu sangat semula jadi dan intuitif. Kebarangkalian bagi pengukuran X untuk menghasilkan hasil tertentu mungkin bergantung pada sama ada atau tidak Y
juga diukur
tanpa mengira hasilnya.
Jadi tu memberitahu kita apa
kebarangkalian untuk hasil-hasil yang berbeza
dari pengukuran, tapi apa yang berlaku kepada Y atau
pengetahuan kita tentang Y akibatnya?
Jawapannya ialah masih
mungkin ada ketidakpastian tentang keadaan Y sebagai
akibat dari mengukur X
dan melihat hasil tertentu. Dan ketidakpastian tu diwakili oleh formula kat sini untuk kebarangkalian bersyarat
bahawa Y berada dalam keadaan klasikal tertentu
b, diberi bahawa X berada dalam keadaan klasikal,
keadaan klasikal a apa pun,
yang kebetulan kita ukur.
Untuk tepat, kebarangkalian Y berada
dalam keadaan klasikal b, diberi bahawa X berada dalam keadaan klasikal a,
adalah sama dengan kebarangkalian
X berada dalam a dan Y berada dalam b dibahagikan dengan kebarangkalian X
berada dalam keadaan klasikal a.
Jadi kalau kita ukur X, kita akan nampak
keadaan klasikal yang berbeza dengan kebarangkalian yang ditentukan
oleh formula kat sini
dan bergantung pada hasil yang kita dapat, kita mungkin masih ada ketidakpastian tentang keadaan klasikal Y dan
ketidakpastian tu dicerminkan
oleh formula kat sini.
Sebenarnya ada cara yang sangat mudah
untuk mengungkap semua ni dan untuk melakukan pengiraan
bagi kes tertentu menggunakan notasi ket
dan ia macam ni.
Kita mulakan dengan menuliskan
keadaan kebarangkalian XY sebagai vektor macam ni, dan
ini adalah sepenuhnya umum.
Entri dinota sebagai Pab dan ini boleh jadi mana-mana nombor asalkan keseluruhan vektor
adalah vektor kebarangkalian.
Kita boleh ungkapkan ket ab sebagai
tensor product macam yang korang nampak kat sini kemudian kita boleh guna
bilineariti tensor product
dan khususnya fakta bahawa ia adalah linear dalam argumen kedua untuk ungkapkan vektor ni
macam yang korang nampak kat sini.
Apa yang kita buat ialah dengan berkesan mengasingkan vektor asas standard
di sebelah kiri dan meletakkan apa pun yang kita perlukan
di sebelah kanan
untuk membolehkan tu sebab ia akan mendedahkan apa yang berlaku bila kita
ukur sistem pertama X.
Khususnya kebarangkalian
untuk mendapat hasil tertentu a adalah jumlah semua kebarangkalian yang muncul dalam
kurungan bersebelahan ket a.
Dan dengan syarat mendapat
hasil tertentu a, vektor kebarangkalian yang menghuraikan ketidakpastian apa pun yang kekal tentang Y
adalah vektor yang ada dalam
kurungan bersebelahan a.
Kecuali kita perlu menormalisasikannya untuk menjadikannya vektor kebarangkalian dan itu bermaksud kita mesti bahagikan vektor tu
dengan jumlah entri dalam vektor tu untuk membentuk vektor kebarangkalian.
Di sini ngomong-ngomong, hasil tambah diambil keseluruhan
c dalam gamma berbanding b hanya untuk guna nama pemboleh ubah yang berbeza supaya tak ada kekeliruan
tentang skop
pemboleh ubah kalau nak cakap.
Hasil tambah dalam pengangka
dan penyebut perlu dianggap sebagai perkara yang berasingan dan kita boleh elakkan sebarang peluang
kekeliruan tentang tu
dengan menggunakan
pemboleh ubah yang berbeza untuk dua hasil tambah.
Ni contoh cepat untuk
menggambarkan macam mana semua ni berfungsi.
Andaikan XY adalah pasangan bit dalam keadaan kebarangkalian ni kat sini untuk memahami apa yang berlaku
bila kita ukur bit pertama
dan kita tak buat apa-apa kepada yang kedua, kita tulis vektornya macam yang korang nampak kat sini di mana ket sifar dan ket
satu di kedudukan pertama
diasingkan macam yang
kita huraikan beberapa saat tadi.
Kemungkinan pertama ialah
hasil pengukuran adalah sifar dan kebarangkalian
berlakunya adalah jumlah kebarangkalian
di dalam kurungan
WEBVTT
yang di-tensor ke ket sifar. Jadi kita dapat satu per dua belas tambah satu perempat, iaitu satu pertiga dan
dengan syarat hasil sifar.
Keadaan kebarangkalian Y
menjadi vektor ni dinormalisasikan atau bersamaan dibahagikan dengan kebarangkalian
yang baru kita kira, dan jadi apa yang kita dapat ialah
vektor ni kat sini.
Kemungkinan kedua ialah hasil pengukuran adalah satu dan pengiraannya
dilakukan dengan cara yang sama menggunakan sebutan kedua dalam ungkapan
berbanding sebutan pertama. Dan kalau korang nak sahkan butiran, silakan macam biasa hentikan video untuk bagi diri korang masa nak buat tu.
Korang boleh lakukan pengiraan yang sama
untuk cari apa yang berlaku bila
Y diukur berbanding X.
Ia adalah kaedah yang sama dengan simetri antara dua sistem.
Kali ni kita tulis
vektor kebarangkalian macam ni, mengasingkan vektor asas standard di sebelah kanan macam yang korang nampak kat sini,
tapi selain tu ia berfungsi
dengan tepat cara yang sama.
Korang juga boleh guna kaedah ni
untuk lebih dari dua sistem.
Ia boleh jadi agak bersepah
untuk tulis semua ungkapan yang diperlukan, tapi secara konseptual ia adalah
tepat idea yang sama.
Akhirnya, untuk bahagian pelajaran
tentang maklumat klasikal, kita akan tengok operasi
ke atas keadaan kebarangkalian
berbilang sistem. Mengikut penaakulan yang sama yang kita dah nampak beberapa kali.
Kita simpulkan bahawa operasi kebarangkalian ke atas berbilang sistem adalah macam
operasi kebarangkalian ke atas sistem tunggal yang diwakili
oleh matriks stokastik.
Tapi kali ni matriks-matriks tu
mempunyai baris dan lajur yang bersesuaian dengan hasil darab Cartesian set keadaan klasikal sistem individu.
Iaitu kita hanya
melihat sistem kompaun seolah-olah ia satu sistem tunggal dan kembali kepada huraian macam mana operasi kebarangkalian berfungsi
untuk sistem tunggal dari
pelajaran sebelumnya.
Ni adalah contoh operasi yang dipanggil operasi controlled-NOT
ke atas dua bit X dan Y.
Ini sebenarnya operasi deterministik dan cara ia berfungsi ialah
kalau X sama dengan satu, maka operasi NOT dilakukan ke atas Y
dan selain tu kalau X sama dengan
sifar maka tak ada apa yang berlaku.
Bit X kadang-kadang
dipanggil bit kawalan sebab ia menentukan sama ada
atau tidak operasi NOT digunakan pada Y
dan Y dipanggil bit sasaran sebab ia adalah bit yang dikenakan operasi NOT.
Korang juga boleh bayangkan
menukar peranan X dan Y supaya Y menjadi bit kawalan
dan X menjadi sasaran, tapi itu adalah operasi yang berbeza
dari yang dihuraikan kat sini sebab operasinya tak
simetri antara X dan Y.
Kedua-duanya dipanggil
operasi controlled-NOT, dan kita hanya perlu tentukan
yang mana satu bit adalah bit kawalan dan
yang mana satu adalah bit sasaran.
Operasi ni mempunyai tindakan
yang korang nampak kat sini ke atas keadaan asas standard dan korang boleh semak
tindakan tu dengan takrifan
operasi. Dan ni adalah perwakilan matriks bagi operasi.
Bila kita fikirkan tentang operasi ni, kita bayangkan bahawa ada
dua bit berasingan ni dan ia memainkan peranan yang saya baru huraikan dengan
X sebagai bit kawalan
dan Y sebagai bit sasaran, tapi sebenarnya tak ada apa-apa
tentang tindakan kat sini atau perwakilan matriks ni
yang menuntut kita
fikirkan dua bit ni sebagai bit berasingan.
Kita boleh secara alternatif fikirkan sahaja
tentang operasi ni sebagai operasi deterministik ke atas sistem yang mempunyai empat keadaan klasikal
yang kita dah putuskan untuk namakan
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 dan 1,1.
Ni adalah contoh lain
operasi kebarangkalian ke atas dua bit, yang bukan operasi deterministik kali ni.
Operasi ni menetapkan Y sama dengan X dengan kebarangkalian satu perdua dan selain tu ia pergi cara lain dan ia menetapkan X sama dengan Y.
Operasi ni tak ada nama khas ia hanya dimaksudkan sebagai contoh.
Dan ni adalah perwakilan matriks
bagi operasi ni.
Korang boleh nampak ia boleh dinyatakan sebagai purata dua matriks, satu yang mewakili operasi deterministik
di mana Y ditetapkan kepada
nilai apa pun yang disimpan dalam X dan yang lain yang menetapkan
X sama dengan Y.
Jadi kat sini kita nampak bahawa kita boleh ambil purata matriks stokastik untuk mendapat yang baru macam yang kita ada dalam pelajaran sebelumnya.
Sekarang, jom kita fikirkan
soalan berikut. Andaikan kita ada dua
operasi kebarangkalian setiap satu pada sistemnya sendiri
dihuraikan seperti biasa oleh matriks
stokastik dan untuk tepat, katakan M adalah
operasi kebarangkalian
ke atas sistem X dan N adalah
operasi kebarangkalian ke atas sistem Y.
Soalannya ialah kalau kita
serentak lakukan M ke atas X dan N ke atas Y, macam mana kita huraikan
kesan yang ada padanya
ke atas sistem kompaun XY?
Dengan berfikir tentang
ni secara intuitif seketika, kalau kita serentak
lakukan dua operasi ke atas sistem masing-masing,
maka kita sebenarnya
melakukan operasi ke atas sistem kompaun, jadi ia patut dihuraikan
oleh matriks stokastik.
Jawapan ringkas kepada
soalan ni ialah matriksnya diperolehi dengan mengambil tensor product, bukan antara vektor macam
yang kita bincangkan tadi,
WEBVTT
tapi antara matriks dalam kes
ni, matriks M dan N.
Jadi jom kita luangkan beberapa saat
untuk bincangkan tensor product matriks kemudian kita akan
kembali kepada soalan ni.
Ni adalah takrifan
tensor product antara matriks dan
ia sangat analog dengan tensor product antara vektor.
Kalau kita andaikan bahawa dua
matriks yang kita kerjakan ditulis dalam bentuk yang korang nampak kat sini supaya entri M dinota alpha ab sebagai a dan b
merentasi set keadaan klasikal sigma dan entri N dinota
oleh beta cd sebagai c dan d
merentasi set keadaan klasikal gamma.
Maka hasil darab M dan N adalah matriks yang korang nampak kat sini.
Apa yang kita ada adalah serupa
dengan tensor product antara vektor.
Baris dan lajur M tensor N bersesuaian dengan pasangan keadaan klasikal yang ditulis sebagai rentetan kat sini,
dan entri adalah hasil darab entri yang bersesuaian M dan N.
Ni adalah cara lain untuk tuliskannya dalam istilah entri individu
matriks-matriks ni.
Entri ac bd bagi M tensor N adalah hasil darab entri ab
bagi M dan entri cd bagi N.
Ada cara lain untuk
menghuraikan M tensor N, iaitu ia adalah
matriks unik yang mengubah sebarang vektor berbentuk Phi tensor Psi
kepada tensor product M yang digunakan kepada Phi dengan N yang digunakan kepada Psi, dan itu mesti benar untuk setiap pilihan
vektor-vektor Phi dan Psi ni.
Satu cara untuk fikirkan tentang
ni ialah tensor product matriks serasi sempurna dengan tensor product antara vektor.
Ini adalah persamaan yang korang
secara semula jadi berharap adalah benar dan memang ia benar.
Dalam istilah matriks yang
ditulis secara eksplisit, kita boleh takrifkan tensor
product macam yang korang nampak kat sini.
Ada banyak titik dalam persamaan ni dan ia bertujuan untuk
menggambarkan corak, yang adalah corak yang sama
yang kita ada untuk vektor kecuali sekarang kita ada baris dan lajur
berbanding hanya vektor lajur.
Kalau tak jelas, contoh
berikut mungkin membantu.
Kat sini kita bercakap tentang
tensor product dua matriks dua kali dua.
Kita dahulukan tulis empat
salinan matriks kedua, satu untuk setiap entri matriks pertama.
Kita darabkan setiap
salinan matriks kedua ni dengan entri yang bersesuaian
matriks pertama,
kemudian kita kumpulkan semuanya menjadi
satu matriks empat kali empat macam yang korang nampak kat sini.
Kita juga boleh takrifkan
tensor product tiga atau lebih matriks dengan cara yang analog dan mungkin cara paling mudah untuk ungkapkan ni
adalah macam yang korang nampak kat sini
di mana kita ada formula untuk setiap entri tensor product, yang hanya merupakan hasil darab
entri yang bersesuaian.
Korang juga boleh takrifkan tensor product tiga atau lebih matriks secara rekursif dalam istilah tensor
product hanya dua matriks macam yang kita ada untuk vektor.
Dan satu nota terakhir ialah
tensor product matriks adalah multiplikatif, yang bermaksud hasil darab
tensor product
adalah sama dengan tensor
product hasil darab.
Korang boleh fikirkan tentang
ini sebagai generalisasi formula dari beberapa saat tadi untuk tindakan tensor
product matriks
ke atas tensor product vektor. Dan sekali lagi, ini adalah sesuatu yang kita
tentulah berharap adalah benar dan kita boleh gembira ia memang begitu
dan kita akan guna fakta ni
bila kita perlu.
Dan sekarang kita boleh kembali kepada
soalan dari tadi yang tanya macam mana kita huraikan
kesan melakukan operasi M ke atas sistem X
dan operasi N ke atas sistem Y bersama-sama sebagai operasi
ke atas sistem kompaun XY.
Dan jawapan kepada
soalan tu ialah tindakannya dihuraikan oleh
tensor product M dan N.
Tensor product mewakili kebebasan kali ni antara operasi berbanding apa yang kita nampak
sebelum ni untuk vektor kebarangkalian.
Ni contoh cepat. Andaikan kita lakukan
operasi kebarangkalian yang dihuraikan oleh matriks ni ke atas bit X.
Ini kebetulan adalah operasi
yang kita nampak dalam pelajaran satu dan kita serentak lakukan
operasi NOT ke atas bit Y.
Operasi gabungan ke atas pasangan XY oleh itu diwakili oleh tensor product matriks yang bersesuaian dengan dua operasi ni.
Ni yang ke atas X dan
ni adalah operasi NOT ke atas Y dan kita dapat matriks ni
yang korang nampak kat sini.
Dan korang boleh nampak bahawa memang
ini adalah matriks stokastik dan itu akan sentiasa begitu.
Tensor product mana-mana
dua matriks stokastik atau sebarang bilangan matriks
stokastik akan sentiasa stokastik.
Adalah sangat biasa
bahawa kita temui situasi di mana satu operasi dilakukan
ke atas satu sistem dan tak ada yang dilakukan kepada sistem lain.
Dalam situasi ni, kita ikut tepat preskripsi yang sama dengan pemahaman bahawa tak buat apa-apa diwakili oleh matriks identiti.
Contohnya, kalau kita ada dua bit X dan
Y dan kita tetapkan semula bit X ke keadaan sifar, yang adalah perkara yang sama
sebagai melakukan fungsi
sifar malar ke atas X dan kita tak buat apa-apa kepada Y, maka operasi yang terhasil ke atas pasangan XY
WEBVTT
diwakili oleh tensor product ni kat sini.
Semua ni tergeneral
ke sebarang bilangan sistem dan kita akan nampak beberapa contoh tambahan bila kita beralih ke konteks kuantum, yang berfungsi dengan tepat cara yang sama
kecuali kita ada matriks unitari berbanding matriks stokastik, dan itu sudah cukup tentang
maklumat klasikal buat masa ni.
Sekarang kita akan alihkan perhatian
ke maklumat kuantum dan macam mana ia berfungsi untuk berbilang sistem.
Coraknya adalah sama macam
yang ada untuk maklumat klasikal.
Kita boleh tengok berbilang sistem kuantum sebagai sistem kompaun tunggal dan gunakan apa yang kita tahu
dari pelajaran sebelumnya.
Sekali lagi, tensor product
akan memainkan peranan penting dan secara keseluruhan kita mendapat huraian macam mana maklumat kuantum
berfungsi untuk berbilang sistem.
Yang sangat analog
dan serupa secara matematik dengan apa yang kita baru nampak untuk
maklumat klasikal.
Kita akan mulakan dengan keadaan kuantum.
Keadaan kuantum berbilang sistem diwakili oleh vektor lajur yang mempunyai entri nombor kompleks
dan norma Euclid sama dengan satu
macam keadaan kuantum
sistem tunggal.
Kali ni indeks
vektor keadaan kuantum bersesuaian dengan hasil darab Cartesian set keadaan klasikal
bagi sistem-sistem individu
sebab sekali lagi, itulah
set keadaan klasikal bagi sistem kompaun.
Contohnya, kalau X dan Y adalah qubit, maka set keadaan klasikal
bagi pasangan XY bersama-sama adalah hasil darab Cartesian bagi
abjad binari dengan dirinya sendiri,
yang boleh kita fikirkan sebagai
set semua rentetan binari panjang dua.
Jadi vektor-vektor yang korang nampak kat sini semuanya adalah contoh vektor
keadaan kuantum XY.
Kalau kita nak, kita boleh secara alternatif tulis
vektor-vektor ni macam ni di mana kita ada ket berasingan
bagi setiap qubit
di mana tensor product
antara keduanya adalah tersirat.
Atau kita juga boleh tulis
simbol tensor product secara eksplisit macam ni kalau korang prefer.
Dan pilihan lain ialah
beri subskrip pada ket dengan nama sistem
yang diwakilinya macam ni.
Dan korang boleh buat ni dengan
simbol tensor product atau tanpa.
Itu kadang-kadang sangat berguna untuk kekalkan kejelasan.
Ni hanyalah gaya yang berbeza untuk ungkapkan vektor yang sama dan kita boleh pilih mana-mana yang kita nak atau yang kita prefer atau
yang paling masuk akal
untuk situasi yang ada. Bila benda-benda jadi lebih
complicated contohnya, kita mungkin putuskan bahawa satu dari
gaya ni menambah kejelasan
dan kita bebas buat
pilihan mana yang kita nak.
Tensor product vektor keadaan kuantum juga adalah vektor keadaan kuantum.
Untuk kes dua sistem contohnya, kalau Phi adalah vektor keadaan kuantum
bagi sistem X dan Psi adalah vektor keadaan kuantum
bagi sistem Y,
maka tensor product Phi dan Psi adalah vektor keadaan kuantum XY.
Kita panggil keadaan macam ni keadaan hasil darab dan serupa dengan apa yang kita nampak dalam konteks kebarangkalian klasikal, ia mewakili kebebasan
antara sistem X dan Y.
Jadi contohnya, kalau seorang ada makmal
di satu bahagian dunia dan dia cipta sistem X dan inisialisasikannya ke keadaan kuantum Phi
dan orang lain di
bahagian lain dunia secara bebas menginisialisasikan sistem Y ke keadaan kuantum Psi,
maka kalau kita pilih untuk fikirkan tentang XY sebagai membentuk satu sistem walaupun ia dua bahagian atau di bahagian yang berbeza di dunia,
maka sistem kompaun XY berada
dalam keadaan Phi tensor Psi.
Semua ni tergeneral kepada
lebih dari dua sistem dengan cara yang semula jadi.
Kalau kita ada
keadaan kuantum Psi1 hingga PsiN bagi sistem berasingan Xn hingga Xn, maka tensor product n vektor ni
mewakili keadaan kuantum, yang sekali lagi dipanggil keadaan hasil darab bagi sistem kompaun X1 hingga Xn.
Ni adalah contoh keadaan kuantum
dua qubit.
Walaupun mungkin tak
kelihatan macam tu dengan serta-merta. Ia adalah contoh keadaan hasil darab sebab kita boleh tulis
ia sebagai tensor product macam yang korang nampak kat sini.
Jadi ia adalah contoh
keadaan hasil darab tanpa mengira macam mana ia ditulis, apa yang relevan ialah sama ada
mungkin atau tidak untuk tuliskannya sebagai tensor product.
Keadaan kuantum ni, walau bagaimanapun, yang sekali lagi adalah keadaan dua
qubit bukan keadaan hasil darab.
Ia serupa dalam semangat dengan
contoh yang kita nampak dalam konteks kebarangkalian dua bit rawak yang berkorelasi sempurna
dan hujah yang sama mendedahkan ia tak boleh ditulis
sebagai tensor product.
Jadi jom kita pindahkan ni ke sini dan jom kita tengok hujahnya dengan lebih terperinci.
Jom kita bayangkan bahawa kita
boleh tulis keadaan ni sebagai tensor product
dua vektor Phi dan Psi.
Entri yang bersesuaian
dengan keadaan klasikal 0,1 adalah sifar untuk vektor ni, yang boleh kita nampak hanya dengan melihatnya.
Ini bagaimanapun akan membayangkan, kalau vektor tu adalah tensor
product dua vektor bahawa entri sifar Phi
kali entri satu Psi
akan sama dengan sifar, tapi itu bermaksud sama ada
entri sifar Phi atau entri satu Psi sama dengan sifar
atau kedua-duanya boleh sama dengan sifar, tapi itu bercanggah dengan fakta
bahawa dua hasil darab ni mesti kedua-duanya bukan sifar.
WEBVTT
Ia sama dengan satu
per punca kuasa dua dua. Hujahnya sebenarnya hampir
sama dengan yang kita ada dalam konteks kebarangkalian.
Tak ada apa-apa yang unik
kuantum tentang ni langsung.
Dalam mana-mana kes, apa yang kita dapati ialah keadaan asal bukan keadaan hasil darab.
Perasan bahawa tak penting
bahawa dua nombor kat sini adalah satu per punca kuasa dua dua.
Yang penting hanyalah
kedua-dua nilai bukan sifar.
Keadaan kuantum tertentu ni
adalah sangat menarik. Ia adalah contoh
keadaan berentangle dua qubit.
Kita akan bincang lebih tentang
entanglement kemudian dalam siri ini.
Entanglement boleh jadi complicated, terutamanya bila kita
bercakap tentang keadaan kuantum dalam rumusan umum
maklumat kuantum,
tapi kat sini dalam huraian ringkas maklumat kuantum entanglement adalah bersamaan dengan ketiadaan kebebasan.
Jadi untuk vektor keadaan kuantum,
kalau ia bukan keadaan hasil darab, ia adalah keadaan berentangle
dan keadaan tertentu ni
biasanya dianggap sebagai
contoh tipikal keadaan kuantum berentangle.
Dan sebenarnya, kita kadang-kadang
fikirkan tentang keadaan ni sebagai mewakili satu unit entanglement, terutamanya bila kita
fikirkan tentang entanglement
sebagai sumber yang boleh
digunakan untuk buat benda yang menarik.
Keadaan kuantum yang
kita baru bincangkan adalah satu dari empat keadaan Bell yang digelar, yang korang boleh nampak kat sini
bersama-sama dengan nama
yang biasa digunakan untuk keadaan-keadaan ni, Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus dan Psi minus.
Semuanya berentangle
dan ia memang membentuk asas untuk ruang semua
vektor yang mewakili keadaan dua qubit.
Jadi empat vektor ni bersama-sama
dipanggil asas Bell.
Ia adalah koleksi keadaan kuantum yang sangat biasa ditemui dinamakan
sempena John Bell, yang adalah ahli fizik yang membuat sumbangan yang sangat penting
kepada kajian entanglement pada tahun 1960-an.
Ni adalah beberapa contoh terkenal keadaan kuantum tiga qubit.
Yang pertama dipanggil keadaan GHZ.
Ia macam keadaan Phi
plus yang kita baru nampak kecuali untuk tiga qubit berbanding dua.
Dan contoh kedua dipanggil keadaan W dan ia kelihatan macam yang korang nampak kat sini, jadi ia seragam merentasi
tiga rentetan binari
panjang tiga yang mempunyai
tepat satu bit ditetapkan ke satu.
Kedua-dua keadaan ni bukan keadaan hasil darab dan kedua-duanya mempunyai sifat menarik dan timbul agak kerap sebagai contoh, jadi elok untuk tahu tentangnya
dan kita akan nampak ia lagi.
Seterusnya kita akan bincangkan
pengukuran sistem dalam keadaan kuantum.
Mengikut penaakulan yang sama
yang kita ikuti setakat ni dalam pelajaran, iaitu fikirkan tentang berbilang sistem
seolah-olah ia sistem tunggal. Kita segera sampai kepada huraian macam mana pengukuran
berbilang sistem kuantum berfungsi
dengan syarat semua
sistem diukur.
Iaitu kalau kita ada
vektor keadaan kuantum Psi yang mewakili keadaan kuantum n-tupel sistem
X1 hingga Xn dan kita ukur
keseluruhan sistem kompaun, yang bersamaan dengan mengukur
setiap satu sistem individu, maka setiap n-tupel
keadaan klasikal yang mungkin akan jadi hasil pengukuran
dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan
nilai mutlak kuasa dua entri Psi yang
bersesuaian dengan n-tupel tu.
Contohnya, kalau kita ada
pasangan sistem XY dalam keadaan kuantum ni kat sini, maka kalau kita ukur kedua-dua sistem,
maka kita akan dapat hasil sifar hati maksudnya sifar untuk pengukuran X dan hati untuk pengukuran Y
dengan kebarangkalian sembilan per dua puluh lima dan kita akan dapat hasil satu
picik dengan kebarangkalian 16/25.
Tu memang agak mudah. Kita pada dasarnya hanya abaikan fakta bahawa ini adalah dua sistem berasingan dan kita tengok ia seolah-olah
ia satu sistem tunggal,
tapi ini menimbulkan
soalan semula jadi berikut, yang kita dah fikirkan
dalam konteks klasikal.
Andaikan kita ada dua sistem X dan Y yang secara kolektif
berada dalam keadaan kuantum dan kita tak ukur kedua-duanya, tapi
kita hanya ukur satu sistem.
Katakan kita ukur sistem X dan kita tak buat apa-apa kepada Y.
Sudah tentu, kita juga boleh tanya apa yang berlaku kalau kita ukur Y bukan
X dan secara lebih umum apa yang berlaku kalau kita ada
tiga atau lebih sistem
dan kita ukur subset wajar daripada ia. Tapi bila kita dah ada
jawapan kepada soalan ni, kita akan ada jawapan kepada
soalan-soalan tu juga.
Kita tahu bahawa secara umum
vektor keadaan kuantum pasangan XY mengambil
bentuk yang korang nampak kat sini, dengan andaian biasa bahawa sigma dan gamma
adalah set keadaan klasikal
X dan Y masing-masing.
Entri vektor ni dinota
oleh alpha ab merentasi semua pilihan a dan b yang mungkin,
dan ia boleh jadi nombor kompleks apa pun yang menyebabkan vektor ni
menjadi vektor unit.
Sekarang kita dah tahu bahawa kalau
kedua-dua sistem diukur, maka kita dapat kebarangkalian untuk hasil-hasil yang berbeza yang mungkin
WEBVTT
dengan mengambil nilai mutlak kuasa dua entri yang bersesuaian.
Dan jadi kalau hanya X diukur, maka kebarangkalian untuk
mendapat hasil tertentu a diberikan oleh ungkapan ni,
kita hanya jumlahkan semua
hasil b yang mungkin, yang boleh diperoleh
kalau Y juga diukur walaupun ia tak diukur pun.
Ideanya adalah sama macam dalam
konteks kebarangkalian.
Kebarangkalian untuk mendapat
hasil tertentu bila X diukur tak mungkin
bergantung pada sama ada Y juga diukur atau tidak.
Jadi ni memberitahu kita apa
kebarangkalian untuk hasil-hasil yang berbeza yang mungkin.
Selain tu, akan ada perubahan
dalam keadaan Y akibat dari melakukan
pengukuran ke atas X dan mendapat hasil tertentu.
Jadi jom kita tengok macam mana ini berfungsi.
Serupa dengan apa yang kita buat dalam
konteks kebarangkalian, kita boleh ungkapkan
vektor keadaan kuantum Psi macam yang korang nampak kat sini
di mana Phi a adalah vektor ni untuk setiap pilihan keadaan klasikal a bagi sistem X,
kita guna bilineariti
tensor product macam sebelumnya.
Hanya sekarang kita pilih untuk namakan
vektor-vektor berbeza ni Phi a, hanya untuk kemudahan.
Kita dah perhatikan bahawa kebarangkalian pengukuran menghasilkan
setiap hasil yang mungkin a adalah macam yang korang nampak kat sini,
tapi sekarang kita boleh nampak bahawa kebarangkalian ni sama dengan norma Euclid
kuasa dua bagi vektor Phi a,
dan sekarang akibat dari pengukuran X memberikan hasil tertentu a, kita ada bahawa keadaan kuantum
sistem kompaun XY
menjadi keadaan ni yang
korang nampak kat sini.
Macam yang kita ada untuk sistem tunggal, keadaan runtuh pada dasarnya, tapi ia tak runtuh
sepenuhnya secara umum,
ia hanya runtuh setakat yang perlu untuk konsisten
dengan pengukuran X menghasilkan hasil a.
Keadaan kuantum Y menjadi Phi a dinormalisasikan bermaksud kita
bahagikan dengan norma Euclidnya
supaya ia menjadi vektor unit. Ini analog dengan apa yang berlaku dalam
konteks kebarangkalian di mana berbanding dengan membahagi
dengan norma Euclid,
kita bahagikan dengan jumlah
entri Phi a untuk mendapat vektor kebarangkalian.
Tapi kat sini sebab kita
bercakap tentang keadaan kuantum, kita bahagikan dengan norma Euclid
untuk mendapat vektor keadaan kuantum.
Jom kita tengok beberapa contoh untuk nampak macam mana ini berfungsi
untuk keadaan tertentu.
Ni adalah keadaan yang akan kita fikirkan. Kita mengandaikan bahawa X dan Y adalah qubit dan ia berada dalam keadaan tertentu Psi ni.
Dan katakan X diukur.
Kita mulakan dengan menuliskan keadaan
Psi macam yang korang nampak kat sini, dengan berkesan mengasingkan
faktor asas standard X
dan men-tensor ia dengan apa pun yang kita perlukan untuk mendapat keadaan asal.
Macam dalam huraian umum
dari tadi.
Kebarangkalian untuk mendapat hasil sifar adalah norma Euclid kuasa dua
bagi vektor ni kat sini.
Perkara yang kita tensor ke ket sifar dalam ungkapan kita bagi vektor Psi.
Dan jadi kebarangkaliannya adalah tiga perempat dan dengan syarat
mendapat hasil sifar.
Keadaan kuantum
pasangan XY menjadi ni di mana kita normalisasikan
vektor yang di-tensor ke ket sifar,
dan itu bersamaan dengan
membahagi dengan punca kuasa dua kebarangkalian yang
kita baru kira.
Kita kemudian boleh permudahkan
dan inilah yang kita dapat.
Kebarangkalian untuk mendapat
hasil pengukuran satu dikira dengan cara yang sama.
Kita ambil norma Euclid kuasa dua
bagi vektor ni kat sini. Perkara yang di-tensor ke ket
satu dalam ungkapan kita bagi Psi
dan kebarangkalian yang terhasil
adalah satu perempat, yang memang mesti begitu tentu saja, sebab kebarangkalian kita
mesti berjumlah satu.
Dalam kes ni, keadaan kuantum XY menjadi ni di mana sekali lagi kita normalisasikan dengan membahagi dengan norma Euclid
supaya kita dapat vektor
keadaan kuantum ni sebagai hasilnya.
Kaedah yang sama digunakan
dengan cara simetri, kalau Y diukur berbanding X.
Ni adalah vektor keadaan kuantum asal, dan kali ni sebab Y
diukur berbanding X,
kita ungkapkan vektor Psi
macam yang korang nampak kat sini, di mana kali ni kita asingkan
vektor asas standard Y
berbanding X yang di-tensor
dengan apa pun yang kita perlukan untuk mendapat ungkapan Psi.
Melalui pengiraan, yang boleh korang semak dengan
menghentikan video kalau korang nak.
Kita nampak bahawa kebarangkalian
untuk mendapat hasil sifar adalah Phi8 kali ni, dan ni adalah vektor keadaan kuantum
yang terhasil dengan syarat
mendapat hasil tu.
Dan kebarangkalian untuk mendapat
hasil satu adalah tiga per lapan, dalam kes mana ini adalah
vektor keadaan kuantum kita.
Korang boleh guna tepat kaedah yang sama dalam kes korang ada lebih dari dua sistem dan mana-mana subset wajar
daripada ia diukur.
WEBVTT
Dan ada contoh
dalam kandungan buku teks untuk pelajaran ni yang boleh korang check kalau korang berminat.
Ringkasnya, kita sentiasa boleh bahagikan sistem kepada dua koleksi berasingan, yang diukur
dan yang tidak.
Dan bila kita dah buat tu, kita kembali kepada kaedah
yang baru saya huraikan, dan itulah macam mana pengukuran untuk berbilang sistem kuantum berfungsi.
Dan sekarang akhirnya, kita beralih kepada operasi unitari
ke atas berbilang sistem.
Menggunakan idea asas yang sama bahawa berbilang sistem boleh dilihat sebagai sistem kompaun tunggal.
Kita simpulkan apa yang korang nampak
ditulis kat sini pada skrin, operasi kuantum ke atas sistem kompaun diwakili oleh matriks unitari
macam yang kita ada untuk sistem tunggal dan khususnya baris dan lajur matriks unitari tu bersesuaian dengan hasil darab Cartesian
set keadaan klasikal koleksi
sistem apa pun yang kita bincangkan.
Contohnya, kalau kita ada sistem X
yang keadaan klasikalnya adalah satu, dua, dan tiga dan Y adalah qubit,
maka matriks yang korang nampak kat sini adalah contoh matriks unitari yang mewakili
operasi ke atas pasangan XY.
Butiran macam mana kita
menyusun hasil darab Cartesian yang kita bincangkan sebelumnya tak penting untuk
kes contoh ni, ia hanya matriks enam kali enam
yang kebetulan unitari.
Tak ada yang istimewa tentangnya, walaupun ia dibina dari
beberapa matriks penting.
Tujuannya ialah korang boleh
pilih mana-mana matriks unitari enam kali enam dan ia akan mewakili
operasi unitari ke atas XY.
Kalau kita gunakan koleksi
operasi unitari secara bebas setiap satu pada sistemnya sendiri, maka tindakan semuanya bersama-sama
ke atas sistem kompaun diberikan
oleh tensor product.
Dan kat sini pada skrin korang boleh nampak kenyataan yang lebih tepat
bagi fakta tu.
Kalau operasi unitari kita dihuraikan oleh matriks unitari U1 hingga Un satu untuk setiap sistem kita,
maka tindakan gabungan
ke atas sistem kompaun diberikan oleh tensor
product U1 hingga Un.
Sekali lagi, serupa dengan apa yang kita ada dalam konteks kebarangkalian, contoh penting ialah kita guna operasi unitari
U ke atas sistem X dan kita tak
buat apa-apa kepada sistem lain Y.
Operasi ke atas XY yang kita dapat adalah U di-tensor dengan matriks identiti.
Matriks identiti
menggambarkan tak buat apa-apa kepada Y.
Kadang-kadang berguna untuk tulis secara eksplisit bahawa matriks identiti ni
bersesuaian dengan sistem Y, hanya untuk buat formula lebih jelas.
Dan satu pilihan ialah
beri matriks identiti subskrip macam ni yang menunjukkan sistem yang ia bekerja ke atasnya.
Bila ia cukup jelas, kita biasanya tak
bother dengan subskrip, tapi bila benda-benda jadi lebih complicated, ia boleh sangat membantu.
Dan kita juga boleh fikirkan tentang
kes simetri di mana operasi unitari
V digunakan kepada Y dan tak ada yang dilakukan kepada X,
dan kali ni operasi unitari yang terhasil
ke atas XY diwakili oleh tensor product ni kat sini.
Dan sekali lagi, kita boleh letak subskrip pada
matriks identiti kalau ia membantu.
Ni adalah beberapa contoh spesifik.
Kalau X dan Y adalah qubit dan kita
lakukan operasi Hadamard ke atas X dan kita tak buat apa-apa kepada Y, kita dapat matriks yang korang nampak kat sini.
Sebaliknya pula, kalau kita lakukan operasi Hadamard ke atas Y dan kita tak buat apa-apa kepada X, susunan tensor product
adalah terbalik.
Dan jadi kita dapat matriks
yang korang nampak kat sini.
Tak setiap operasi unitari
ke atas sistem kompaun boleh dinyatakan sebagai tensor product.
Kalau kita ada tensor product,
maka kita ada kebebasan.
Dan ada beberapa
contoh asas operasi yang tentunya
tidak bertindak secara bebas ke atas berbilang sistem.
Contohnya, kalau X dan Y mempunyai
set keadaan klasikal yang sama, yang boleh jadi mana-mana
set keadaan klasikal sigma,
maka kita boleh fikirkan tentang
operasi swap ke atas pasangan XY.
Operasi ni tak mengubah susunan dua sistem, kita masih ada X di
kiri dan Y di kanan, sebaliknya ia mewakili
menukar kandungan
dua sistem tu. Kat sini korang boleh nampak ia dinyatakan
dalam bentuk persamaan di mana kita ada tensor
product dua keadaan kuantum.
Cara lain untuk tuliskannya adalah sebagai
matriks macam yang kita nampak kat sini.
Cara korang boleh fikirkan tentang
huraian ni ialah ia memberitahu korang apa yang berlaku untuk vektor asas standard.
Dan bila kita tahu apa yang berlaku
untuk vektor asas standard, kita tahu apa yang berlaku untuk
keadaan kuantum sewenang-wenangnya oleh lineariti,
yang sebenarnya juga benar untuk
ungkapan ni kat sini.
Jadi operasi tertentu ni kat sini kebetulan adalah operasi deterministik juga sebagai operasi unitari.
Kalau X dan Y adalah qubit contohnya, kita dapat perwakilan matriks
ni kat sini.
Ni adalah sambungan menarik
antara operasi swap dan empat keadaan Bell, yang ditunjukkan kat sini
untuk kemudahan.
Operasi swap meninggalkan
tiga yang pertama daripadanya tidak berubah, tapi ia meletakkan tanda tolak di
hadapan keadaan Psi minus,
WEBVTT
jadi ada sesuatu yang
istimewa tentang yang satu tu.
Korang boleh semak persamaan-persamaan ni secara langsung dengan melihat vektor-vektor ni dan fikirkan apa yang berlaku
untuk keadaan asas standard
menukar dua keadaan klasikal untuk tiga keadaan Bell yang pertama
tak buat apa-apa kita dapat keadaan yang sama macam yang kita mula dengan.
Dalam kes keempat bagaimanapun, tanda tolak berkesan
berpindah dari satu sebutan ke yang lain bila kita lakukan swap keadaan klasikal,
dan itu bersamaan dengan mendarabkan vektor dengan tolak satu.
Jadi melakukan operasi swap entah macam mana mengeluarkan tanda tolak
dari keadaan Bell keempat ni.
Kita akan ada lebih nak cakap tentang
persamaan-persamaan ni kemudian, tapi sekarang jom kita beralih kepada
jenis operasi lain, iaitu operasi terkawal.
Kita nak andaikan bahawa X adalah qubit dan Y adalah sistem apa pun yang korang nak.
Kalau U adalah operasi unitari ke atas Y, maka operasi controlled U ke atas XY adalah operasi yang
dinyatakan kat sini.
Pertama, menggunakan notasi ket dan kemudian menggunakan apa yang
dipanggil matriks blok korang hanya bayangkan isi matriks lebih besar ni
dengan yang lebih kecil di mana sifar ni sebenarnya mewakili matriks
yang diisi dengan sifar.
Jadi setiap empat blok ni mewakili matriks yang mempunyai
bilangan baris dan lajur yang bersetuju dengan bilangan
keadaan klasikal Y.
Idea operasi terkawal, yang kita dah temui
dalam konteks klasikal bila kita bincangkan operasi
controlled-NOT,
ialah kalau X ditetapkan ke sifar,
maka tak ada yang berlaku kepada Y.
Tapi kalau X ditetapkan ke satu,
maka U digunakan ke Y.
Jadi X dipanggil qubit kawalan, dan Y dipanggil sistem sasaran, yang secara umum tak
perlu jadi qubit.
Untuk contoh spesifik,
yang baru saya sebut, kita ada operasi controlled-NOT.
Kalau qubit pertama ditetapkan
ke sifar, tak ada yang berlaku. Dan kalau qubit pertama ditetapkan ke satu, maka operasi NOT atau bersamaan,
operasi sigma X digunakan
ke qubit kedua.
Dan ni adalah perwakilan matriksnya.
Kita bercakap tentang dua qubit kat sini, jadi kita boleh sama-sama
putuskan bahawa qubit kedua adalah kawalan dan yang
pertama adalah sasaran.
Untuk menghuraikan operasi tu, kita hanya tukar susunan
dalam tensor product, dan hasilnya adalah matriks
yang korang nampak kat sini.
Kalau berbanding operasi controlled-NOT, kita fikirkan tentang operasi controlled sigma
Z atau controlled Z.
Kita mendapat perwakilan matriks
ni kat sini. Dan untuk yang ni, sebenarnya tak kira
yang mana kawalan dan yang mana sasaran.
Kita dapat hasil yang sama mana-mana cara.
Kita boleh pergi lebih jauh dan kita boleh fikirkan tentang operasi controlled swap.
Dan kat sini kita
bercakap tentang menukar dua qubit, jadi kita akhirnya dengan tiga qubit bila kita sertakan qubit kawalan.
Perwakilan matriks setiap
kelihatan macam ni.
Ia adalah operasi yang agak istimewa dan ia dikenali sebagai operasi Fredkin, atau lebih biasa gate Fredkin.
Bila kita fikirkan tentangnya
sebagai gate dalam circuit, kita akan bincangkan circuit dalam pelajaran seterusnya.
Contoh terakhir ialah operasi controlled,
controlled-NOT, yang sekali lagi adalah
operasi ke atas tiga qubit.
Dan ni adalah perwakilan matriksnya. Operasi ni jauh lebih dikenali
sebagai operasi Toffli atau gate Toffoli.
Kita akan bincangkan lebih lanjut
dan kita akan nampak mengapa ia dan operasi Fredkin are sangat penting
operasi dalam pelajaran kemudian.
Dan itulah penghujung pelajaran kedua. Dalam pelajaran ni, kita bincangkan macam mana maklumat kuantum berfungsi untuk berbilang sistem.
Harap korang akan join saya untuk
pelajaran ketiga tidak lama lagi, yang adalah tentang circuit kuantum
protokol dan permainan.
Bye sampai jumpa lagi.